- [Kelly Clarkson]
Hello, you look so good!
They don't do that for everyone.
- [Faith Hill] Yeah, they do.
- No, they don't! You look so great!
- You look amazing!
- You look fantastic in this!
- I've missed you!
- I know, I'm never anywhere but here.
- I mean, you are working
your tail off, girl!
- I know, I'm taking the summer off.
I'm very excited.
It's my first summer
off since I was like 16.
- Really?
- Yeah. And you know, when things happen
that's when people start going,
"Hey, but I have this.
Hey, but there's this."
And you're like "No".
But speaking of girls, I have to say
this is one of my best moments of my life.
I've had a few times that
I've randomly run into her
and pretended it was totally normal.
I was with Reba and they were like,
"We're going to this dinner!"
and all of a sudden, you're there.
And I was like, "Yeah,
it's totally normal."
I'm like ♪It matters to me♪
I totally wanted to see-
Do you remember this night though?
Do you remember?
- [Faith] Yes! Yes!
- [Kelly] I went to go see Shania.
You did too.
I was with Reba
and I was pretending
I was Meryl Streep right there.
I was so chill about it.
But legit, I was so excited.
- No, same.
- [Kelly] My friends
afterwards, we were just like,
"Do you remember how I
pretended that was normal?"
I was very excited about that
night but I was wondering,
cause we just were talking
about girls nights out,
do you do that with your daughters?
Do you ever say, "Tim you're
not allowed" and you just go?
- [Faith] It just happened.
- [Kelly] It just
happened? What'd y'all do?
- Well, he was not allowed
because he was actually working.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's a
good time to do it though.
- It is, yeah.
- Cause then you don't feel as bad.
You're like, "Well you're
working, it's your fault."
- That's one way to look at it, I guess.
Gracie, our oldest, we
have three daughters,
Gracie just turned 25 last week.
This week, we went on a girls' trip
and had the best time,
the four of us together
and Gracie's best friend.
Girl, I'm all about the dancing.
- Oh, I love dancing.
- [Faith] I cannot dance at all
and I'll be the first to admit it.
I know I can't dance, but I do not care.
I don't care.
- It should be whatever
it should be though.
It feels good just to move your body.
- It should be whatever it should be.
That's when people go, "Mm-hm, 'kay."
- [Kelly] No, you know what they say?
Look, I just went to a concert
Lemme tell ya, this lady in the front-
I was like, One, what are you on, ma'am,
and two, she was living her best life
and it was beautiful to watch.
Like she was just so into it,
moving, and it feels good.
- [Kelly] So now is a
look at her show "1883".
You can see it on Paramount Plus.
This show, "1883" it's your
first major acting role?
'Cause I know that you
were in "Stepford Wives",
- Yes!
- and you've been in some things.
I love that one.
So was it something that
you've always wanted to do
and you dipped your toes in a little bit
but then you decided to just jump in?
- Yes. I started singing in church,
but the first thing that I did,
when I was in lower school,
middle school, high school,
were plays. I was on stage all the time.
Then my career took off,
no time, had babies.
Kept on having babies.
It felt like I was having
babies all the time,
and I had done a couple of things.
I did "Stepford Wives" with an amazing cast.
Amazing cast.
It wasn't the best experience.
So I said I will never, ever, ever, ever
do anything like that, a
movie, because it took so long.
The waiting for me,
you have to understand-
- Hurry up and wait
- I cannot, I have to be busy doing stuff.
Anyway, then I did an independent
thing called "Dixieland".
You know,
I've read a lot of scripts
over the years and-
- [Kelly] Nothing ever really hit ya?
- Nothing hit me or the
timing wasn't right,
and for the script to have been
so incredibly well written,
I honestly had never
read anything like it.
We're talking about "1883".
So we just made the decision to do it.
Tim and I have been
married 26 years this year.
- Congratulations. That can be hard.
- Really?
- Not all of us make it.
- It's okay girl.
- That's amazing!
Were you excited about doing it together?
- [Faith] Gosh, yes.
- Or were you a little intimidated by it?
- [Faith] Well, I'm intimidated by him
because he's an amazing
actor, first of all.
All of the actors on the show,
everyone was so top of the game,
behind the camera, in front of the camera,
but I did have to say,
I did have the rule, for me, personally,
because we've been together for so long,
and we are together all the time-
It's glorious.
- We love it. We love
it. All the togetherness.
- It is the best!
It's so good.
- 24/7
- 25/7
- It is kind of cool
though, the different role.
Is it cool to play someone back then?
'Cause you shot in Texas, my own state,
also, I live in Montana as well
and you shot in Montana as well.
So, wait, that's really
hot or really cold.
Which one was harder?
- Okay. I'm from Mississippi,
so the humidity, the heat I could-
- [Kelly] You're kind of used to that.
- I could deal with it. Texas though was-
- It's God's hairdryer.
- [Faith] Different. That's good!
But the cold,
the wind combined with the cold in Montana
was almost too much to bear.
It is off the chart.
- [Kelly] If you're not
dressed properly, it slaps you.
- [Faith] It really pierces
your entire everything.
But my rule with Tim, I said,
"Look, if we're gonna do this together,
we cannot run lines together, ever.
We cannot talk about the scene
that we're filming tomorrow, ever,"
because it's like-
- You wanted it to feel fresh
and you want it to be
something else separate?
- [Faith] Well, that was, in my opinion,
the only way for me to bring-
to make it feel real and authentic
and it had to be when
the cameras were rolling,
we're on set, roll.
That was the first time I
met James, was on that set
and we were working together
when we were filming.
I know him so well so
otherwise I'd have been like,
"Hmm maybe you shouldn't do that."
You know what I'm saying?
- [Kelly] And then you start judging it.
- "Don't do your face like
that when you say that word."
And him to me, the same.
I'm, again, being funny.
- Again, being funny. She loves him.
- So much! I do, I really do.
- [Kelly] She loves him! I know, I know.